parle-moi de l'homosexualité qu'est-ce
que tu en penses je suis pas contre
ça veut dire que tu es court j'ai pas
dit que j'étais bourre je dis que
j'étais pas contente non je sais pas je
te demande si ça veut dire que tu es
pour non
en ce qui me concerne moi non ce qui me
concentre les autres ça me dérange pas
j'ai beaucoup de copains qui sont
homosexuels qui sont des très bons
copains en général ils ont du goût
ils ont des savoir-vivre ce sont des ce
sont des amis
excellents plus fidèles que les autres
non pas
obligatoirement
le sont des gens qui ont du goût en
général tu ne ressens pas de jeunes
alors contact absolument pas
j'ai eu un secrétaire pendant quelques
années qui était qui était homosexuel je
veux dire mais en général tu sais parle
de paquet là